i'm abby hornacek this is tucker carlson
and i'm jessica tarlov
this is the fox news rundown
friday june 18th 2021
i'm dave anthony while republicans
battle democrats in congress
hoping to win back control of the house
and senate next year
others in the gop are looking to 2024.
i still feel very strongly about the
things that need to be done in this
country
i think we missed a lot of opportunities
during the trump years to get things
done that we should have gotten done
and there's going to be a lot to fix
after four years of joe biden
we speak with past and maybe future
presidential candidate chris christie
i'm chris foster we're getting less bang
for our buck these days with inflation
higher than it's been in years
i don't think they're going to be here
by the end of the year and certainly by
this time next year i think prices will
come back in but
you know it's uncomfortable certainly
now and for the next few months
and i'm todd pyro i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
it's happened again republicans took
obamacare to the supreme court
and lost this time in a 7-2 ruling
the justices didn't even consider the
merits of the case
telling the group of republican-led
states they had no standing no right to
sue in federal court
overturning lower court decisions in the
gop's favor
that the health care law is
unconstitutional after congress repealed
the penalty for not having insurance
undermining the law's mandate to have
coverage democrats hailed the supreme
court ruling house speaker nancy pelosi
the affordable care act endures as a
pillar of american health and economic
security
former president obama who signed the
act into law in 2010
urged more americans to sign up for a
health plan the senate's majority leader
proclaimed
the aca is here to stay chuck schumer on
the senate floor right after the ruling
and now we're going to try to make it
bigger and better
establish once and for all affordable
health care as a
basic right of every american citizen
for republicans it's back to the drawing
board
sounds to me like the folks on the court
decided they wanted to dodge the issue
former new jersey governor chris
christie also ran for president in 2016
and the republican
may run again in 24. normally when
courts especially the supreme court
finds a process reason not to hear
something
it's because they don't want to deal
with the substance reason and they
probably didn't have a consensus on the
substance reason
and that's very interesting given all
the appointments republicans have had to
that court now
when you think about the three that
president trump had
and sam alito and clarence thomas
and john roberts of all republican
appointees on the court
that means that you couldn't get five of
those six to agree that obamacare was
unconstitutional
as the texas court had found so it seems
to me that you know some of those people
that president trump appointed
more likely than not given the way
justices alito and thomas
have voted before uh would seem to me
that at least one if not more of those
three
decided they didn't want to deal with
the substance of the issue and they took
the dodge
you know for a long time republicans
have accused democrats of of using the
court to try to get
things changed that they can't do and
say legislatively
republicans have tried numerous times to
use the court to get rid of obamacare
and it hasn't worked so what is
next with health care policy for
republicans in your view
well listen first off republicans had
the opportunity to do it when they were
in control of all three areas right
house senate and the white house and
they couldn't get it done and so that
was a failure
quite frankly of the folks in the
congress who were in control of the
congress at the time
who couldn't put together a plan that
could muster a majority of republican
votes in both the house and senate and
so
you know i think what we need to do is
to re-examine how we're approaching this
entire issue
and come up with a plan that we can get
majority republican support behind
and that's going to take a little
thinking and a little talking with all
the people
in the house and in the senate on the
republican side because let's face it if
things go the way i believe they will in
2022
we're gonna be back in control of the
house and we could well be in control of
the senate as well
so you know we're gonna have another
opportunity to put some things on
president biden's desk
to make his life difficult in this
regard and we should get a consensus
among our own party
which is the big failing that we haven't
done as a party over the during the
trump years
at the moment the big issue is
infrastructure trying to come up with a
compromise
and democrats may go on their own and
and do even more than what the
compromise
is look i think republicans have put
forward some very reasonable
ideas on infrastructure and i think what
the american people want from the
infrastructure plan is for the money to
be spent on infrastructure
on roads and highways and bridges and
tunnels and airports
uh the the electric grid and wi-fi
um those are the things they wanted
spent on and they don't want it spent on
social programs
so you know i think if if republicans
put together a really solid plan in that
regard
i think it'd be very difficult for
president biden to say no
and so we've just got to keep digging
away at it and not give in
uh and i think if the democrats do go
forward with the plan
that president biden put forward um it's
gonna be bad for the country
but good for the republican party
because it's gonna make them seem even
more extreme
and give us an even better chance of
winning back the house in the senate
in 22. when it comes to those midterms
though
you have the republicans who are in
congress you're also going to have
a lot of involvement by former president
trump he's certainly
still very much involved in the
republican party politics leading the
way
how do you see him looming over the next
elections
listen i think that he'll play an
important role in districts where
he is popular and i think if if he's
smart he'll stay out of districts where
he isn't
um the goal here is to win back a
majority in the house in a majority in
the senate
i think that you know a lot of mistakes
were made that cost us the united states
senate
in that georgia special election with
too much uh
talk of looking backwards and rigged and
stolen elections
and those are not things that people
vote for and by the way those georgia
elections prove
that it's not what people vote for so i
hope that whoever is going to go out and
support
uh 2022 congressional candidates and i'm
certainly going to be one of those folks
we need to be talking about a
forward-looking
positive agenda from us and a
real specific criticism of the things
that president biden and the democrats
are doing
and no discussion of 2020. 2020 is over
it's in the rearview mirror we should
keep it there and any conversation
that was by president trump or anybody
else is destructive to the republican
party
but in 2024 if former president trump
runs
again 2020 will certainly be a big issue
won't it
well you would think it would be
although what i would hope is
if the president ran again that he would
be talking about the future and not the
past
and i think the only chance that
republicans have to win in 2024
is to be talking about the future and
not the past no matter who the candidate
is
what about you you've been talked about
a lot obviously you know that
for 2024 you have said that you were not
going to make up your mind i guess
right until after 2022 correct yes sir
i would rule it out i wouldn't rule it
out at all i still feel very strongly
about the things that need to be done in
this country
i think we missed a lot of opportunities
during the trump years to get things
done that we should have gotten done
um and there's going to be a lot to fix
after four years of joe biden
and so uh you know certainly giving it
thought um but i think it's much too
early to make that kind of decision the
world changes so quickly
that to make a decision now would be
foolish so we'll wait we're gonna work
hard to help people
in the midterms in 2022 and help the
party but both the congressional level
and the governor level
and then we'll uh we'll see what it
looks like in uh in december of 2022.
i mean it's certainly not unheard of joe
biden
ran three times hillary ran twice mitt
romney ran twice bob dole ran twice
ronald reagan even ran twice so it's not
out of the
ordinary for someone to take a second
crack at it and be successful
what would you think you would have to
do differently to be successful well the
times will be different and i certainly
learned a good deal from the last race
uh which was probably one of the most
unusual ones in american history
but i think you know what you have to do
is to
tell the american people the truth they
deserve the truth and they've gotten a
lot of falsehoods told to them
over times over the last number of years
they need the truth told to them
directly
bluntly and they need a plan that makes
them understand that our children's
education is the most important thing
that this country can focus on making
sure our kids are being taught
the right things about our country and
our history and that education and a
great education is available
to every child in this country that's
the only thing that's going to help us
beat china
in this long struggle we're now engaged
in with them
and we need to have someone who's going
to be much tougher on china that we have
certainly with joe biden right now
and quite frankly even then we had with
president trump who who regularly called
presidency a good person i don't think
presidency is a good person
i don't think presidency deserves credit
for much of anything he's a dictator
um he's engaged in genocide in his own
country
to repress political thought and
opposition
and he is stealing american intellectual
property
left and right and breaking trade
agreements on a regular basis
this is not a good person this is not a
friend this is an adversary and it's one
of the places where president trump
i think made a big mistake in in calling
presidency a good person and a friend
what if donald trump is a candidate in
2024 again
he announces in 2023 that he's going to
run again would that stop you
no it would not okay
you don't if it's possible that you
might be on the same stage with some
other people like maybe marco rubio runs
again maybe ted cruz runs again it's
it's possible right sure look
i don't think i i think the decision of
running for president
is an intensely personal one and one
that you've got to decide in your own
heart in your own mind
whether it's something you want to do
and whether you have something unique to
offer the country
and that should not be determined by any
but whether anybody else runs or not
if you let other people determine
whether you're going to run or not
um you probably aren't fit to be
president anyway you brought up china i
want to go there because of
what's going on with everyone wanting
another investigation into the origins
of kovid
china's not gonna cooperate how
do we do this how do you think it should
be done to try to figure out
you've been a investigator prosecutor
over in your career
how would you do it well i think between
both our intelligence agencies and
capability
and also we need to put heat on the
world health organization
um you know the world health
organization wants to be funded by the
united states
wants us to be a part of what they do
they should be demanding of china
to give straight answers on what's going
on here and we need to use them as a
tool as well
or they become much less useful to us
going forward
because if they can't help determine
what caused the worldwide pandemic
then why do we have the word health
organization at all
you had covert yes sir how difficult was
that was it
was it a scary moment scary time for you
it was very scary for me because i spent
seven days in the intensive care unit
and so it was a very difficult time for
me and a scary time for me and for my
family
but fortunately i got great health care
at the hospital in marstown new jersey
and uh
i took the monoclonal antibody treatment
which i really do believe
was determinative in me getting a good
result
and so i think you know i have to tell
you i'm so grateful to the american
pharmaceutical industry
when you think about what that industry
has done for the entire world
in the creation of monoclonal antibodies
as a treatment
and in the creation of these vaccines um
nowhere
else in the world could have gotten this
done and i think we need to be taking a
whole different look at our
pharmaceutical industry a lot of
politicians
use the pharmaceutical industry as a
pinata and they're certainly not perfect
but let me tell you they just saved the
world you have been very vocal trying to
get people
to get vaccinated is it worrying you to
see the demand slow
some and and and more people especially
who might be along the conservative
line of thinking not wanting the shots
it is and i'll tell you why i you know
my view on this is everyone's got the
right to choose what they want to do
but to me it's like putting your seat
belt on in the car
you know it's not going to guarantee you
that if you get in that serious accident
that you might not be hurt or even
killed
but it makes it much much much less
likely and
these vaccines have proven to be
extraordinarily effective
with almost no downside to them this is
a very
random dangerous virus you do not want
to play with it
because if you get it it can cause you
real real serious problems
former new jersey governor 2016
presidential candidate republican chris
christie thank you very much for joining
us
always great to be with you call anytime
[Music]
this is todd pyro with your fox news
commentary coming up
you may have noticed things cost more
now demand for goods and services is
higher as more people are getting
vaccinated for coronavirus and
businesses and travel restrictions are
lifted
supply though has not caught up with
that demand fed chair jerome powell
predicts that'll work itself out and
that the high inflation rate we're
seeing won't last long but
bottlenecks hiring difficulties and
other constraints could continue to
limit how quickly supply can adjust
raising the possibility that inflation
could turn out to be higher
and more persistent than we expect
overall for now consumer prices are
about five percent higher than this time
last year
the fastest pay since 2008. take out
food and energy which fluctuate more
and it's the highest inflation rate
since 1992. well we're seeing it for a
lot of
uh commodities so copper prices lumber
prices
oil is up mark zandy's the chief
economist at moody's analytics
and industrial goods uh in large part
because of global supply chain
disruptions related to the pandemic
we're also seeing big price increases uh
in
industries that are just uh normalizing
getting back to pre-pandemic kind of
pricing like the airline industry or the
rental car business
or uh restaurant uh uh
prices they're just getting back to
where they were so that's where the
biggest price increases are
at least at this point in time how much
of this is a mirage
i mean some prices dropped at the start
of the pandemic so as if you look at the
year-over-year inflation obviously it
looks like it's
possibly worse than maybe it really is
is it a function of that or is it still
higher
relative to what we were paying for
things before the pandemic
oh inflation's up but it's not you're
right it's not as up as
uh to the degree that the the the
year-over-year numbers suggest that's
because if you go back a year ago
obviously that was the teeth of the
pandemic
when businesses were shut down into
slashing prices to
generate any kind of demand they could
so when you compare to what happened
last year
inflation looks really really high it's
not
but it's still up nonetheless i mean
there's still are a lot of disruptions
out there that are
you know making it more difficult uh for
uh producers to produce and the result
is uh higher prices
i i you know i don't think they're gonna
be here by the end of the year and
certainly by this time next year i think
prices will come back in but you know
it's uncomfortable
certainly now and for the next few
months just looking at the politics of
it i mean the biden white house says
look this just this is a validation of
our policies it means that
demand is up republicans are saying look
it's jimmy carter it's the late 70s all
over again
um how much do presidents at policies
really affect things like inflation and
gas prices i mean you're saying it's
mostly due to the supply chain
yeah this is the pandemic right um you
know the pandemic nailed the economy
the businesses had to shut down and and
uh things went dark for a while and and
now we're
opening uh reopening and we're reopening
very very rapidly demand is surging as a
result
and it's taking a little bit of time for
manufacturers and home builders and
all kinds of businesses to turn the
lights back on and start
you know getting back up and running at
full tilt so you know
it's demand supply you get a big surge
in demand supply hasn't kept up quite
yet and so you get these price jumps but
supply will catch up you know businesses
can make a lot of money here you know
they're getting a really good price and
they'll
figure out how to ramp up activity at
the same time
you know people who are buying stuff are
going to respond to they're not going to
they're going to adjust like home
builders are already trying to think of
ways of
you know building homes with less lumber
so we're all doing that
for the things that we're paying more
for so demand and supply adjust and
i suspect by the fall and again by the
end of the year the prices will
come right back in how about home prices
um they've been
basically out of control people are uh
people are looking to buy is there a
housing shortage is that being
exacerbated by the lumber shortage
which you know will work itself out
within a year yeah well demand for
housing has gone skyward right because
mortgage rates have gone to
record lows i mean they're still close
to three percent for a 30-year fix i
mean that's just you know incredible
an incredible bargain and then the work
from anywhere dynamic that was
uh created by the pandemic also you know
juiced things up and that
got layered on top of a very severe
shortage of
of homes particularly affordable homes
lower price middle price point homes
you know they they never really got
built at any significant degree after
the financial crisis so
it's a confluence of things that are you
know come together and created this
surge in prices
uh but you know i i do think once
mortgage rates start to push up a little
bit they're already starting to push up
and you can kind of feel demand is
already starting to weaken
because of the affordability issues and
of course the builders are now
responding because they can make money
even with these higher lumber prices
they can make a lot of money
and so we're getting more supply so we
will see i think house price growth also
moderate the other thing of course is
going to happen here is as as
the economy does reopen and work from
anywhere dynamic does
start to unwind at least to some degree
people start going back to new york and
l.a and san francisco you know that's
going to take a little bit of juice out
of the market so i would expect house
price growth here to slow and
some some of the most active markets may
even see some price decline
how about gas prices some analysts are
saying look i see a big energy spike
the next two three years do you agree
disagree how come
no i don't i mean because there's a
surface of oil uh capacity out there i
mean
prior to the pandemic the globe was
producing 100 million barrels of oil a
day
got down to 90 million barrels a day
because demand collapsed during the
pandemic now demand is right back up
uh and so we've seen oil prices come
back up but you know these
the producers of oil particularly the
big global producers saudi arabia russia
they're only slowly being bringing back
that uh that
capacity they took offline back online
because they're enjoying these higher
prices
but the higher prices will ultimately
get them to you know open up the spigot
we'll get more oil we'll go back up to
100 million barrels a day and you know i
think
oil prices will come right back in i
mean just to give you a number oil today
is going for
you know say 70 75 bucks a barrel you
know in
you know when everything kind of irons
itself out it should be back down to
around 50 55 bucks a barrel so that
means
the difference between a gallon gasoline
regular uh unleaded going for over three
dollars a gallon to something less than
three dollars a gallon okay
even with summer demand it'll just work
itself out
yeah i'm kind of distracting from the
vagaries of the you know the seasonality
here yeah you might see
you know particularly this summer
because everybody wants they want to go
out they want to travel their pen
up so and they can't go overseas because
the pandemic is still raging so
they probably stick close to home so
yeah maybe this summer you know for the
next few months it'll be
elevated but you know looking through
that i do think oil prices and gasoline
prices will come right back in
let me ask about jobs and wages um on
one hand new unemployment claims are up
for the first time since april yet we
have all these restaurant owners saying
i can't get anybody to come and work now
is it as simple as
look one has nothing to do with the
other some industries are laying off
people while hospitality is just trying
to get back up to speed
yeah the ui claims they go up and down
and all around week to week i wouldn't
pay any attention they are they are
coming in i mean in fact last week they
only rose because two states reported
higher ui
claims uh you know that could just be
measurement issue you know the
reporting there's a lot of squirrely
things going on in various ui systems so
i wouldn't read anything into that the
the job market is
improving very rapidly a lot of open
positions a lot of hiring going on
you know layoffs aren't record loans
it's a really good job market so the led
market is
is tight i i do think what's going on
with restaurants and
uh you know hotels and you know all
these industries that got shut down
during the pandemic
they all came back to life all at the
same time
and you know the employers put up the
proverbial help wanted sign
everywhere at the same time and it just
takes a little bit of time for people to
sort
who got laid off or haven't been working
you know been home taking care of kids
or elderly parents
to sort out their life they gotta you
know figure that out
and they can't do that in a week or two
or three maybe not even a month or two
or three
but i suspect by you know september when
schools reopen
in earnest and you know people have had
a chance to kind of figure things out uh
you know
the restaurants will be able to find
those workers hotels will be able to
find the staff and you know these
liberal shortages will abate
wages have gone up a little past
expectations most people's expectations
over the last couple of months and
do you expect that to continue and how
does that play into inflation are we
hitting a
point where just naturally it's time for
wages to go up and maybe prices to go up
yeah wage growth is held up admirably
well during the pandemic
you know and they're they're strong and
i i would expect them to
continue to accelerate because the labor
market
remember back before the pandemic i know
it's hard because it's just such a
long time ago in every sense but the
biggest problem for businesses
across the board bar none was the labor
market it was
it was really tight excruciating
excruciatingly tight
people were having trouble finding
workers and they were pushing up wages
we're just going right back to that so
you know the pandemic was this very dark
interlude you know
and now we're going to get to the other
side and you know we're going to be
faced with the same kind of
situation that was before the
demographics are you know tough here
and so wages are going up now does that
have to be that doesn't necessarily have
to be inflationary
because the good news here is that
productivity growth has also picked up
quite
meaningfully since the pandemic hit and
you know some of that's the pandemic and
you know won't be sustained
but it does feel like businesses are
really focusing on trying to improve the
productivity of their workforce so
you we could get you know higher wage
growth and stronger productivity growth
that's a win-win everybody wins workers
win businesses when
investors win that's the kind of economy
that we want so
there's reason to be optimistic here
that this plays out in a very positive
way
you mentioned just real briefly one more
question you um you mentioned
people trying to sort out their child
care situation maybe their parental care
situation
and all that is part of what more
liberal democrats in congress are trying
to push in this infrastructure bill what
they're calling human infrastructure of
course republicans are
say no roads bridges broadband internet
have you run numbers on how programs
like
child care some free college could help
productivity to the point where they're
actually cost effective
yeah i mean those kind of programs
infrastructure is more about
productivity
you know helping to improve the uh
output per
worker because you know businesses will
be more productive if they have better
infrastructure
the child care the education the housing
that's about improving labor force
participation so we've got you know a
lot of workers that
you know we have pretty low labor force
participation rates in this country
compared to other developed countries
particularly for
uh female workers and in that that
largely goes to the
cost of of working you know the child
care costs the commute costs those those
kinds of things
you know the the issues around paid
family leave uh
and so if we can improve those things if
we can make it cheaper for people to
work they'll work and we'll get higher
labor force participation
and both are important to long-term
economic growth we need productivity
gains but we
also need to attract more people into
the workforce because again our number
one problem
not too distant future is going to be
finding you know workers mark sandy
chief economist at moody's analytics
mark thank you very much
thanks chris i appreciate the
opportunity
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network i'm
ben dominic publisher of the federalists
and i'm inviting you to join a new
conversation with the smartest thinkers
out there
about the country and where we're going
subscribe to the ben dominic podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcast.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
[Music]
father's day is this weekend time to
celebrate the contribution of dads
father's day is observed every year on
the third sunday of june and the holiday
goes back more than a hundred years
sonora smart dodd the daughter of an
american civil war veteran is generally
credited with coming up with the idea
she was moved by a church sermon about
how anna jarvis had founded mother's day
in honor of her mother
so dodd requested june 5th her father's
birthday as a day to honor fatherhood
the church finally settled on the date
june 19 1910 when the first father's day
was celebrated in spokane washington
in 1966 president lyndon b johnson
declared the third sunday in june
father's day with a presidential
proclamation happy father's day dads
tanya j powers fox news
it's time for your fox news commentary
todd
pyro what's on your mind that's most of
what dads do is take
it's what we do that line from the movie
daddy's home you know the one that's
always on basic cable at 3 pm on a
saturday
won't go down in history alongside i'm
gonna make him enough or he can't refuse
but no quote sums up fatherhood so
brilliantly
and us dads wouldn't have it any other
way oh sure we still love to complain
about the job
one in which both sleeping and eating
are events that need to be calendared
where your bank account gets drained
instead of direct deposited where your
tiny boss throws major temper tantrums
out of the blue and this doesn't include
any of the gross stuff
but the benefits at this job now that's
where the good stuff is
laughs that validate your reason for
being finger grabs that touch your soul
smiles that melt your heart of course
this father's day is extra special to me
because it's my first and man am i ever
playing the part of dead in the typical
dad ways
if you're a light i'm turning you off if
you are air conditioning
i am turning you up a half degree when
no one's looking
i celebrate a forecast of rain like i
won the super bowl because it means
i don't have to water dad jokes i mean
come on have you seen fox and friends
first
and let's just say the 20 pounds i've
packed on since birth
have put me squarely in dad bod
territory for the upcoming beach season
but while you always here just wait to
see how your life will change once you
have a kid
i love the changes even though it means
an already difficult schedule
has grown near impossible for instance
i never envisioned my life could get any
more taxing than a daily middle of the
night wake up call
ha now mix that in with a 6 30 p.m
bedtime
thanks to baby tasks and there's a good
chance that i lose consciousness by
friday each week
but when i just don't think i can push
it out anymore i get fueled by baby
giggles
and realize there's nothing else i'd
rather be doing let's face it
i already had my dream job before baby i
get to deliver the news
interview guests on the most important
topics of the day and make people laugh
every now and again but now on my first
father's day i know what it's like to
have the greatest job in the world
it's awesome to finally be part of the
club and no
i don't need the ubiquitous tie as a
gift being a dad
is the best gift ever i am todd pyro
anchor of fox and friends first
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news go to
foxnews.com
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa just say
alexa play news from fox in fox news
it's the latest when you need it on
demand
from fox news and amazon alexa